[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINO TORESHKO: Welcome to
Cloud OnAir, Live Webinars
from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Tino
Toreshko, and today, we
will be talking about what's
new in Google BigQuery.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
As I mentioned, my name is
Tino, and I'm a product manager
on Google BigQuery.
I'm actually being joined
by Jordan Togani, one
of our engineering
leaders on Google BigQuery
to help me with the
Q&A here and there.
You can always reach me
on Twitter at the handle
down there and say
I'm with Jordan.
I'm going to volunteer
him for that.
We love talking
to our customers.
We love talking to people
who are using our platform.
We want to know when
things are going well,
when things are not going well.
We want to know what you
would like us to build next.
So please feel free
to reach out to us.
And at the same
time, of course, you
can follow along with our
progress on our release notes.
You can reach us
on Stack Overflow.
We have a public issue
tracker, where you
can submit feature requests.
And so on and so on.
But we're even active
on Reddit, and we
have lots of folks on
places like Hacker News that
are developer advocates, that
you can have conversations
with.
But this is just
another way for us
to reach out to our community
and update you on the things
that we've been
doing so far in 2018.
Well, let's talk about that.
So far in 2018, it's
been five months.
We've released 27 major
features into Beta
and General Availability.
Now, these are major features.
So a lot of features
are coming out
that just don't get
as much attention.
But these are the things
that really our customers
care about.
And for every major
feature that we release,
there's probably a
major back-end feature
that you don't know about.
So things that have to
do with improvements
around performance, durability,
availability, reliability, even
cost, right?
So the things that
you may not notice
until you go and you push
that big red button that says,
wrong query.
Things just might work
better the next time.
And of course,
all these features
appear as they roll out right.
We don't have
maintenance windows.
We don't want to restart your
BigQuery, instances, and things
like that.
You just get features
continuously.
And if you don't know, we
are having a major conference
at the end of July, July 24
and 26, in San Francisco,
where all Google
Cloud platforms are
going to be joined by
our customers or users.
And you'll be able to
hear some product updates.
You'll be able to hear from
our leadership and some user
stories.
And of course, you can connect
with other folks who are
using Google Cloud platforms.
So please come join us.
I'll be there.
Shameless pitch--
I'm actually going
to have two sessions there.
In the first session, I'm going
to be joined by Rick and Kevin
from the Home Depot.
They'll talk about their
journey on using BigQuery
as their enterprise
data warehouse
for all their analytical needs.
And then, the
second session, I'll
be joined by Nicole from
Spotify, DP from Oath, Yahoo,
and a couple of guys from
Twitter, [? Pavan ?] and Roman,
who will talk about
their internet scale
usage of BigQuery as well.
And Jordan is going to
have a session as well.
Jordan's going to be
joined by Lloyd Tabb
from Looker, the CTO of Looker.
And they're going to talk
about some really interesting
concepts around BigQuery.
So please come join us as well.
Well, believe it
or not, BigQuery
has been around for six years.
We went General
Availability on May 1, 2012,
essentially because "The New
York Times" wrote about this.
Google offers
big-data analytics,
which is interesting.
We've grown since
then to incorporate
lots of other features and
lots of other functionality
that kind of extend us
beyond the big data realm.
But we've been at
it for six years,
and we're continuing to
release more and more features.
And again, we'd love
to hear the features
that you care about the most.
And we have lots and
lots of customers.
We're really proud of the
customers that we have
and the journeys that
they've taken with us--
folks like Spotify,
as I mentioned before,
and Home Depot, and Oath.
And these folks are coming
from all kinds of backgrounds
with all kinds of use cases--
gaming, clickstream analytics,
marketing data, retail,
and so on and so forth.
So hopefully, next year
at this time, your logo
will be on this slide as well.
One customer that was
profiled by "Business Insider"
a couple of weeks
ago is Credit Karma.
We've been talking to Credit
Karma for the last two or three
years.
They've been using our
platform for a while.
And so they've committed
to using Google for all
of their analytic needs.
And BigQuery, of course,
is a huge part of that.
Credit Karma is a very
sophisticated engineering
organization.
And they're just
really nice people.
So if you see them,
please say hi to them.
Speaking of sophisticated
engineering organizations,
Twitter has decided to align
with Google Cloud platform
for their data and
analytics needs as well.
So Twitter, of course, is
a very active participant
in the open source community.
They solve very interesting
internet scale platforms.
And the fact that they're
partnering with Google probably
says something about it.
So we'll be looking
forward to working
with Twitter in the future.
So what does 2018 look like
so far for Google BigQuery?
Well, these are some of the
features we've released.
And I'd like to share with
you guys and ladies what
these features are all about.
I'm just going to run
through all of them
and hopefully give you a good
idea of how to use each one.
Well, the first theme
I want to talk about
is richness of functionality.
BigQuery, when it first
started, was a SQL engine
that was just there
to analyze data
that you load into the query.
But over the years,
we've added more
and more functionality
to simplify
how you manage your
data and give you
more functionality around that.
So richness of
functionality is the theme
I'm talking about here.
The first one is DDL,
Data Definition Language.
DDL went beta a few months ago.
DDL essentially allows you
to inline in SQL statements,
allows you to create and
delete tables and views,
virtual views.
So it just makes it much easier
for you to work with your data.
You can always do that using
other types of operations.
One interesting way of working
with Data Definition Language
is using Create Table as select.
So one use case
here for example is,
if you have a table that
isn't partitioned and maybe
doesn't have a specific
column that you'd like,
you can select from that
table and create new columns.
You can filter data or actually
select from any query you want.
You can have
[? joins. ?] You can have
analytic functions in there.
And the results
of that table can
be written into a new table
that may or may not exist.
And then, you can add a
partition there on top.
So this is probably
the number one use
case for Data Definition
Language that we have so far.
So please try out.
We'd love to hear
your feedback on that.
The next feature is Merge.
So BigQuery has had DML,
Data Manipulation Language,
for quite some time now.
Merge is a really
powerful operation
that merges the three statements
that are a part of DML--
like insert, update, and delete.
So in one statement merge,
you can do all the above.
So this is an example of
a merge query right here.
And the typical use
case is that you
might have a table that
has all your inventory.
And this, table of course,
needs to be kept up to date.
As new inventory comes
in, you would probably
want to update your inventory
table with the new arrivals.
And of course, if
there is a product
that's in your
inventory, you might
want to increase the quantity.
And if there is not a
product in your inventory,
you might just want to add it.
So this is what this
statement accomplishes.
And a quick little segue,
BigQuery and technologies
like BigQuery that support DML--
support mutations, updates,
deletes, and inserts--
so BigQuery isn't necessarily
a great technology
where you would want to do
a million individual updates
and deletes.
That's just not how
this technology works.
And any technology that
is similar to BigQuery
has the same
architectural limitations.
But what BigQuery
allows you to do,
it allows you to
work on as many rows
in a table as possible within
one individual statement.
So while we don't offer you
a whole lot of statements
that you want to
make, each statement
can process essentially trillion
rows if you'd like it to be.
We allow you to run
correlated mutations.
What I mean by that is, you can
update, delete, and insert rows
in your table based on
some kind of statement
like a SQL statement.
So here is an example there.
That SQL statement can
be any kind of statement.
It can be joins.
You can have aggregations,
filters, analytics,
and all that typical SQL stuff.
So again, while you could do
lots and lots of statements
on mutability, you
probably shouldn't.
And so the best
practice around BigQuery
is to batch all of your updates,
deletes into single states.
This is, of course, especially
relevant for things like GDPR,
where you might want to update
your data inside of BigQuery.
So we try to make
it easy on you.
The next feature is actually
a data type, numeric.
A numeric is really
a decimal data type
that has actual
precision-- so all the way
up to 38 precise decimal points.
This is especially useful
for financial calculations
where you're keeping track
of money essentially.
It turns out that float is
not a really good data type
for these types of operations.
People don't like
losing parts of pennies
in their calculations.
And neither is integer
because cents exist.
But with this data
type, of course,
we extended all of our
SQL functionalities
so you can run
algebraic and arithmetic
statements in SQL or numeric.
So hopefully, that
simplifies your life.
And let us know how
it works for you.
So we talked about the
features that enrich
the functionality of BigQuery.
The next thing I
want to talk about
are features that
simplify your life, that
allow you to have
a peace of mind
when you're using BigQuery.
The first one this CMEK.
CMEK stands for Customer-Managed
Encryption Keys.
So to take a step back, BigQuery
by default encrypts all data.
At rest and what
BigQuery actually does
is, it chunks all your data
into tiny little pieces
throughout its data centers.
And these little
chunks of data, they're
all protected by their
own data encryption keys.
And on top of that, we
have key encryption keys
that are encrypting the keys
that are protecting the data,
so that in some unfortunate
situation, where
maybe a disc ends up
in somebody's hands,
that data is entirely
useless to those folks--
because not only do we chunk
the data all around our data
centers, we also use two
levels of encryption.
But we are the ones that are
managing your encryption keys.
So for some situations,
our customers
might want to manage
their own encryption keys.
So you bring your
own encryption keys.
You manage them.
You can rotate them.
You can specify these
encryption keys.
You can actually,
with one click,
de-activate the
encryption keys, so
that all data
becomes essentially
inaccessible to
anyone, including us.
So it's a really interesting
and really powerful
security feature for our folks.
And finally, we're keeping
track of everything
that's happening with
encryption keys and audit logs.
This is our paper trail.
You should probably go and
enable all Audit Logs today.
Audit logs keep track of every
single job, every single query
that has occurred
inside of BigQuery.
So when a job started, when
somebody accessed specific data
set, these are of
course immutable.
And you could
actually pop them back
into BigQuery for analysis.
For the last few years, BigQuery
has been a regional service.
But we've only been inside of
the United States and Europe.
But we have lots and lots
of customers in Asia.
The primary reason
for folks in Asia
to actually have
BigQuery in the APAC area
is to minimize transit from
those areas to the United
States or to Europe
because data transfer can
have an additional cost.
Latency-wise, it's not
a huge consideration
because BigQuery takes a
second to process a query.
What's another 100
milliseconds to move that data
from the United States to Tokyo?
But the folks have
been asking for it.
And so we have announced the
rollout of BigQuery General
Availability in Tokyo.
So it covers the region.
So you don't have to
go across the ocean.
And it allows you to keep
your data in one region.
Of course, there
are use cases where
data sovereignty is applicable.
And so we're going to continue
to look into other areas
where that's applicable.
We've rolled out
several features
around transparency of BigQuery.
The first one is, if you are
using the BigQuery UX today,
you can, in real time, see
progress of your query.
You may have noticed
that already, right?
It will say in there-- when
you run a query-- it will say,
your query is on stage 5 of 12.
And it will actually show
you a chart of what's
happening inside of that query.
The second is BigQuery
slots is a unit of compute.
That's how BigQuery
executes its workloads.
You can actually
see how many slots
have been consumed
over the course
of a query in query history.
That might be useful for
some of the folks who are
on our flat-rate pricing model.
And it allows you to calculate
how many slots you really
need to fill your workload.
And finally, on
the bottom there,
one feature that is
really powerful for some
of the more advanced
users is the ability
to create resource hierarchies.
So you can actually think
of these as virtual clusters
nested on top of each other.
But they all share resources.
You can have two
separate clusters-- one
for the analytics team, one
for your data science team.
And they all have
perfect isolation.
But when your data science
team goes on vacation,
those resources
are automagically
available for your
analytics team,
so that no resources are wasted.
So here's an example
of a setup like that,
where we've released
some upgrades
to our monitoring
[INAUDIBLE] that
allow you to track
these hierarchies
and how they're being consumed.
So this functionality
is really interesting.
And reach out to us if you
want to learn more about it.
Self-service cost controls--
so folks talk to us
and tell us that
sometimes, there's
anxiety with the model of
pricing that BigQuery has,
where you pay for every query.
There is anxiety that
you may run a query that
may be too expensive.
Or maybe you'll run
too many queries.
Well, we introduced Cost
Controls a couple of years
ago actually to help
you alleviate that pain.
Now, what you can do is,
you can set usage limits.
You can do it per query, or you
can do it as a daily budget.
And this allows you to prevent
the worst-case scenario in case
you really start
spending a lot of money,
and you have really made
a mistake in your code.
This protects you.
The first one is, you can
set a per-query cost limit.
So for example, you
don't want any query
that processes more than
100 terabytes to ever
be ran in the query.
Or you can set that limit.
The second is, you can set
a per-user daily budget.
For example, you
don't want any user
to run more than 50
terabytes worth of queries
in any single day.
And this, of course,
is a rolling window.
So you don't have to wait
until the end of the day
to have that reset.
And finally, you can set
per-project budgets as well.
So you can say,
every project only
gets access to 100 terabytes
of processing per day.
Now, what happens when you reach
that limit is, BigQuery starts
giving you an error
that says, hey, you've
exceeded your limit.
You can't run any more
queries until your tokens
are refreshed, until
you start using more.
So what we launched
earlier in May
is the automation of the
per-project daily budget.
So you can go into the
BigQuery console today.
You can set the
per-project limit,
and this will take
effect in minutes
instead of having to go through
support and things like that.
And of course, this is a very
interesting topic of discussion
for our customers,
for our users.
So we'd love to hear
more about what else
you'd like to see
from these features.
Finally, BigQuery is being
used for folks from all parts
with all kinds of technologies.
So people who are used to
relational databases, people
who are used to Hadoop,
maybe they're using Kafka,
would like to use all those
technologies in conjunction
with BigQuery.
So we're really focusing
on interoperability.
The first feature I want to
talk about is partitions.
Historically-- it was six years
ago when we first started--
we didn't have any
types of partitions.
We had something
called Table Wildcards.
Table Wildcards allow you
to query table data itself.
So if you have 1,000
tables, they're
all named a similar way, you
can use this functionality
to pick out which tables
you really want to query.
So that's been really
powerful for a long time.
But throughout the
years, folks have asked
for a partition functionality.
So first, we released
a metadata, what
we called natural partitions--
partitions on a column
that doesn't exist,
that had a partition
time predicate.
But since then, folks
had asked for the ability
to set actual user-based
time-stamped columns
as partition keys.
So in this example,
you have a table
that has four columns, ts
and the other three columns
there listed.
And we set ts as
the partition key.
So it's data partition key.
So when you are querying
this table, and you say,
I want ts to be a specific
date time, we will actually
go to just that
partition, hopefully
as the graph demonstrates.
So this is a really
useful feature.
It's also useful when you are
loading data into BigQuery,
or when you are trying to
materialize partition tables
because you can materialize
lots and lots of partitions
with a single command--
because we will look at the time
stamp of every individual row.
And we'll put it in
the right partition.
Hopefully, that's
useful for you.
The next feature is Data
Manipulation Language
on partition tables.
So we've released petitions.
We've released Data
Manipulation Language.
Now, we're kind of merging
these functions together.
So you can actually edit
partition tables with DML.
So in this particular example,
you see that in case I want
to take data from one
partition and do a filter--
where it says
field 1 equals 21--
and move that into a
different partition.
So it's just a very
basic DML statement.
But it allows you to do a lot
with your partition tables.
Hopefully, you find that useful.
The next feature is
Parquet file format ingest.
So if you read the Dremel paper
that was released in 2010,
there's a couple of
concepts that are actually
explained in there.
The first one is the Dremel
execution engine, which
is really what powers BigQuery.
And Dremel and BigQuery
are now the same thing.
The Dremel team is
now a BigQuery team.
And they both kind
of go hand in hand.
But the other concept that
was explained in the paper
is our file format
called [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE] is a
common file format
that Julian and other
folks on the Parquet team
saw as useful and
externalized via Parquet.
But Parquet is now a very
ubiquitous file format.
It's used essentially
by everyone
who's leveraging [? AGFS, ?]
Hadoop, MapReduce, even Spark.
So Parquet is very powerful.
So what we've enabled
this year is the ability
to ingest Parquet
directly into BigQuery.
it's a very useful feature
for a couple of reasons.
For one, just like Avro
file format, it's binary.
So you're not going to have
weird collisions between UTF8
and ASCII.
Whatever data you are loading
into BigQuery from Parquet
is strongly tied.
The second is, Parquet
is highly parallelizable.
So if you load one terabyte
file of Parquet into BigQuery,
we're going to be able to
split it into as many chunks
as we feel is necessary to
ingest that data into BigQuery
very quickly.
Third is, Parquet has a
schema inside of the file.
So you don't need
to define a schema.
Or we don't need
to infer a schema,
so that you can just
take this Parquet file
and load it into
that BigQuery table.
And we will figure
out all the details.
So it's really, really powerful.
We recommend this.
If you have control over which
files are loaded into BigQuery,
Parquet is a great way to go.
And of course, one quick note
on ingest of data into BigQuery.
Ingest is very
compute-intensive operation.
We have to read your files.
We have to process them,
encode them into our format,
compress them, load
them, replicate them
all over the place.
Typically, with
technologies like BigQuery,
this compute capacity
is the same capacity
that consumes your
queries, so that if you're
loading lots of data
into your technology,
your core capacity may suffer.
With BigQuery, we have
a unique architecture,
where the query
capacity is entirely
separate from the
ingest capacity.
So that no matter how much data
you're loading into BigQuery,
your queries don't suffer.
And of course, we also don't
charge for these loads.
So it's kind of like
the best of both worlds.
We don't charge for
this, and it doesn't
affect your query capacity.
We feel like our customers
benefit from this greatly.
And of course, there
are many other formats
that are being used in
the world out there.
And we're going to be
announcing more soon.
And please let us know
if you have a file
format that we don't support.
We'd love to see
which ones are popular
and which ones we should
support in the future.
The last feature out
of the major ones
that I want to talk about
is our continuous updates
to the Simba drivers--
to the ODBC and JDBC drivers
that we work with Simba
to put together.
These updates happen rather
regularly these days.
So we always want folks
to use these drivers
as a gateway to the query.
So some of the things
that we've been working on
is things like support
for partitions, support
for DML and DDL, support
for CMEK, Customer-Managed
Encryption Keys.
So everything that
BigQuery has, we
want in the ODBC
and JDBC drivers.
So they're continuously being
updated as BigQuery features
are rolling out.
We are also working on
making these drivers faster.
So over the past
six months or so,
we've increased performance by
roughly 60% on these drivers.
And we're going to
continue to focus on that.
And finally, we
want these drivers
to be mature and stable,
so our customers get
the best experience this way.
And one final thing that I
didn't really talk about here
is, there's much more that's
happening inside of BigQuery.
As you can see, you may
look in our release notes,
you may notice that
we've increased
a whole lot of quotas.
So for example, the row and
cell size limit, specifically
for CSV and JSON files has
increased from 10 megabytes
to 100 megabytes.
So it's just easier for you
to load data into BigQuery.
And the maximum number
of partitions per table
has been increased to 4,000,
and so on, and so forth.
The other thing
to point out there
is, we've extended our SQL
functionality to have the Error
function and the Safe Prefix.
So you can handle errors
a little bit better
inside of your SQL statements.
Now, a quick segue onto quotas.
BigQuery is a
multitenant system.
So a lot of the
subsystems are shared.
And just like in any
technology, there
are anti-patterns in BigQuery.
There are things that
you as a customer
are allowed to do that may not
work for you if you continue
to do that through scale.
And that essentially is the
truth with every technology.
So in order for us to work
with you in the best way
to use BigQuery, we
have these quotas.
So quotas are there
to protect you guys,
and they're there to
protect us as well.
That said, if you
have specific use
cases where certain quotas need
to be raised, please come talk
to us.
We're always looking for ways
to improve this particular user
experience.
So the quotas are not immunable.
Many of them can be added.
So it would be good if you
do end up in situations where
you're hitting quotas--
come talk to us,
and maybe we'll work on that.
So so far, BigQuery
has, to recap,
released a number of features.
Of course, we have
lots of engineers,
and we have lots of folks
working on more features.
So there will be
many, many more.
And we'll do another
recap just like this.
We will walk through
all the features
that we're releasing
moving forward.
But so far, these
are the features
we've released in 2018.
Again, please do come talk
to us about these and others
that you may need that
we haven't released.
And we'd love to see
how we can help you.
And to wrap up, we,
as I mentioned before,
have our conference in July
24 and 26 in San Francisco.
I will be there.
The vast majority of
the BigQuery leadership
and engineers will be there.
And we'd love to talk to you.
So please come find us.
We'll have a booth.
We'll have sessions.
We'd love to hear
from you-- and great.
Well, stay tuned for a live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Welcome back.
Now, it's time for the
Q&A. We took some questions
from the audience.
And if you have more questions,
please, again, reach out to us.
The first one is, when are some
of these beta features that
are talked about going to
go GA, General Availability?
Well, let me tell you how
our features get released
into general availability.
It's kind of like
the maturity scale.
By the time features hit
General Availability,
they have a support plan.
We have SLAs.
We have our set
[INAUDIBLE] beta engineers
working on these features.
So they are fully supported.
They're locked down, and
we're fully behind it.
By the time these
features are beta,
they're essentially
locked down as well.
From beta to GA, we're
working on maturity,
we're working on performance,
scalability, just
making sure that the
user experience is really
phenomenal there.
But by the time
features are beta,
they're fairly
mature [INAUDIBLE]..
And before they go beta,
of course we have alpha.
And we have Early
Access programs.
And we're always
looking for folks
to try these features out
before they go beta as well.
So it really depends on the
feature from beta to GA.
It's rare that we have features
that take more than a year
to go from beta to GA.
But a lot of these take one
or two quarters generally.
But a lot of folks are using
these features and data
because they're
incredibly useful already.
So I'm not going to stop you.
Next question is, how can I find
out about upcoming features?
Well, we have our blog posts.
We have Twitter.
We have our release notes.
So we try to maintain a
presence around what--
we're trying to update their
customers and our users
with what's happening.
But we do have a roadmap.
And we do have other
features that are coming up.
So to learn more about that,
reach out to your account folks
or reach out to us directly
to get these updates.
Third question, I need to update
thousands of rows in a table,
but the limit for DML
statement is only 200.
That's correct.
So today, a per-table limit
for how many DML statements
you can execute is 200.
But as I mentioned in one
of the earlier slides,
we don't limit how many
rows can be affected
by any of these statements.
So any of those
200 statements can
execute millions, or billions,
or trillions of mutations.
You can work on the whole table
all at once if you'd like to.
So again, a best
practice for BigQuery
is to batch these updates,
and deletes, and inserts
into singular requests.
So you can update
thousands of rows
in a single table using
our correlated, updates
using a subquery in
a single statement
or a couple of statements.
But again, if you have specific
use cases or specific places
where you need these
statements [INAUDIBLE],,
please come talk to us.
Maybe there's a proper use
case, and we can help you.
What partitioning
schema do you recommend?
So we have really three types
of ways to partition your data.
The first one is, you
can just shard your data.
What I mean by that is, you can
create a table for every quote
unquote "partition."
So you can create a table
for every single day
and name it so.
Or you can say games 2018
or 601, games 2018 or 602,
games 2018 or 603.
What we have, as I
mentioned, is the ability
to query specific tables.
So you can say, I want
to query all tables
where the month is July.
And so we will SQL
all those tables,
and we will only select the
tables that fit your predicate.
So that's one way of doing that.
The next way is, using our
natural partitions, which
is a metadata column
a date-time column,
that isn't a column that
is inside of your table.
But it's a metadata column.
And it uses a partition time
product or a partition date
predicate.
That's also one way
of doing things.
But I think, the most useful
way, at least from what
our customers tell us, is
this user-specified column
partition.
So you can actually
set up a table,
where one of your columns,
where one of your values,
is the partition.
So you can say, this time-stamp
column is my partition.
And please use that.
This is really useful
because, again, you
can load data into
BigQuery, into a table,
into multiple
partitions all at once.
Or you can run a select
[? into ?] statement
that writes data to multiple
partitions all at once.
Last question is, how can
I submit feature requests
and get my questions answered?
So I touched upon
this a few times.
There's a few avenues.
We're continuously working on
improving our communication
with our users.
We want to hear from you.
So we're very, very
active on Stack Overflow.
We're very active on Twitter.
And of course, we have something
called An Issue Tracker,
where you can actually submit
your own feature requests.
And we have multiple
plans for support,
from all the way out to
dedicated support engineers who
are working just for you.
And those folks are there
to help you with any issues
you might have, help
you with any features
that you might want to have,
and you want us to know about.
And these folks can help
facilitate any roadmap
discussions with our team.
Great, stay tuned for
the next session--
CE Chat, Wrangling your
Data with Cloud Data Crowd.